[Music]
i love fear fear is fuel
i kind of joke but not really that i put
fear in my bowl of cereal in the morning
and i eat it i was not an athlete as a
kid i say that i was actually allergic
to exercise
so the fact that working out is actually
my life's work
is astonishing definitely to me and
everyone around me
i am a reformed lawyer turned ultra
marathoner head instructor
and vice president of fitness
programming at peloton
and i am here to start fires we can
absolutely change our stories
i am living proof
if you're coming to this class expecting
me to teach you
the nuts and bolts of fitness that's not
going to happen today
in my master class we're going to be
applying the principles of movement
and fitness to business and storytelling
we're going to talk about ways to plot
dreams using things like
journaling and visualization techniques
even if you don't consider yourself
an athlete even if you also think that
you are allergic to exercise
the principles of endurance power
strength they apply to every industry
every day
two weeks before i started working at
peloton i was diagnosed as a type 1
diabetic my pancreas stopped producing
insulin
completely unexpected and in that moment
i had to decide
do i crumble or do i pivot am i a victim
to this
or am i still victorious despite
movement is therapy for me the process
of training and having something to
focus on and having something that was
for me
changed my life now we are going to get
you from wherever you
are to where you want to be we're going
to get uncomfortable
this class is for anyone who has a
glimmer of curiosity about what's
possible
for themselves i'm robyn arson and this
is my master class
this is baby's first master class
[Music]
you